il ya deux principales de manques dans
sa campagne
la première c'est le renforcement du rpt
à enlever du mannequinat rallier pour la
responsabilité des entreprises et la
deuxième c'est de promulguer le
diligence raisonnable dans les
opérations globales et les chaînes
d'approvisionnement des compagnies 1 et
pour cela ce qui est nécessaire c'est un
loi conférence compréhensif qui oblige
aux compagnies d'effectuer la diligence
raisonnable de prévenir est ce qu'on
comprend faire diligence raisonnable
juste pour avoir une idée qu'est ce que
ça signifie rien dire est d'avoir une
loi qui s'occuperait de sa particulière
oui et pour le diligence raisonnable ça
obligerait aux compagnies de identifié
définir les possibles risques de
violation des droits des droits humains
à de les prévenir de mettre en place des
mesures pour prévenir ces violations
d'atténuer et rendre compte pour pour
ses violations donc c'est à dire une
partie ces deux identifier les risques
la deuxième partie parti c'est de
prendre des actions pour les prévenir et
la troisième partie c'est de rentrer ont
publiquement de ce qu'on a fait l'autre
partie important pour un loi c'est pas
seulement de se fier aux compagnies
c'est nécessaire d'avoir ses obligations
pour les compagnies mais aussi on doit
inclure la possibilité de tenir les
entreprises légalement responsable dans
les cours pour assurer que il effectue
cette obligation
et puis c'est là j'imagine que le rôle
de l'ombudsman pour être important les
deux les deux demandes sont
complémentaires mais pas le lier
directement comme vous
vous l'avez mentionné donc selon les
principes directeurs des nations unies
en matière d entreprise et trois humains
ont les personnes victimes à des abus
liés aux compagnies devraient avoir
recours à des mécanismes non judiciaires
hors des courts et aussi des mécanismes
judiciaires
donc pour l'ong mines sont roses c'est
principalement de faire des entrées de
faire des enquêtes indépendantes de
faire des rapports publics et faire des
recommandations pour la prévention un dd
tort à ces recommandations pourraient
être les diriger aux compagnies ou ou à
l'état canadien pour des nouvelles
politiques ou de nouvelles lois les les
investigations les informations am
personnels ne pourront pas être produits
dans des décors découvre donc c'est par
le biais d'eric loi comme ça mais la
façon dans laquelle l'ombudsman et
l'obligation de diligence par nab sont
le premier dès que les recommandations
du bureau de l'ombudsman pourrait
inclure la nécessité d'avoir un loi sur
la diligence raisonnable par exemple